almost like liberal parents are getting
what they voted for I wonder if this
will be enough to change their vote it's
kind of like a simulation how much chaos
can you tolerate before you vote out
Democrats
we're about to find out because our next
guest says thousands of migrants are
living in an abandoned School in the
heart of her neighborhood across from
her child's School
the migrants of Migrant Academy are
loitering drugging drinking and knocking
on doors asking for cash
not even offering to work for cash just
asking for cash
Rachel Maniscalco joins us now
paint a picture for us what is going on
in this neighborhood where you live
where your daughter goes to school thank
you for having me and thank you for
bringing attention to this uh an
untenable situation we live in Staten
Island and you know people know Staten
Island as the most Republican Borough
and we're very proud of that I've never
voted blue a day in my life and I want
that to be very clear my daughter goes
to a private Catholic school and right
across the street is a prior Catholic
school that was supposed to be kept as
an educational facility
and that hasn't happened
um James Otto the former Borough
president assured parents that it would
not be turned into condos he wanted to
keep it educational and that was in 2018
and here we are five years later it's a
migrant condo now it is becoming a
migrant facility and so what are they
doing are they outside are they causing
a ruckus uh well right now because of
how many rallies we've had and how many
protests and how many parents have have
stepped up and been outside of the
school a lot of them come and they don't
want to stay which is what we want
that's what we want we want this city to
understand that we are not going to take
this we are not going to take this um
sleeping or sitting down these are our
kids and you know we don't want them to
feel fearful we we fully accept legal
immigration we welcome those people sure
but we do not accept this as the waiter
are the migrants behaving themselves at
migrant academy uh this one has been
open for only a brief time about two
weeks however the hotel in Travis
another part of Staten Island that was
turned into a migrant shelter about a
year ago those migrants are not they are
wandering they're in people's backyards
knocking on doors they're not working
they're loitering they're drinking
they're doing things they're throwing
trash this is not sustainable what are
these people supposed to do during the
day I guess they're supposed to loiter
and smoke meth because that's what
they're doing right now it's got to stop
and thank you for all your efforts and
for all the moms out there that are
turning things up because absolutely
power to the people that's the only way
the politicians are going to listen
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else